hey guys what's up I'm Tia Maury and I
am actually on set of my new Netflix
show family reunion were awful parents
knocking very soon I'm gonna give you
behind the scenes exclusive sneak peek
of the set you ready
come on let's go this right here is
Madeira house and this is her porch and
we have a lot of scenes here we sip on
lemonade we have tea time and it just
looks so real you could see there's like
flowers but these are real flowers but
they look group right wait is this room
oh my gosh are you guys ready to go
inside in the deers house let's go
[Laughter]
Jordan she always calls me Mom even when
we're not working right she's like mom
mom mom she's so adorable
let me welcome you to my dears throat oh
yeah I'm just missing one other child
she's gonna pop out somewhere is she
okay oh geez so this is my dears house
right yes and here's the beautiful
Loretta you need to teach me how you do
that it's a good face where's Anthony
yep with his kid and here's little
Anthony here's Anthony and Richard
there's me there's Jordan easy right
there you guys want to see what's in the
fridge
ready yeah hey let's go that bridge it's
really it's cold and there's like real
food in here yes smell that do the kids
can actually grab you know some real
juice boxes see like that we have a
dishwasher oh you know what's so funny
don't wait let me see look these doors
actually really open with dishes and
stuff we've actually washed dishes in
here once an hour since the show takes
place in Columbus Georgia we have a lot
of like pies we have a lot of cookies
right and who'll wait you guys who eats
most of the sweets on set
hey you guys let's ask if Loretta
I'll show us Oh
well I guess on the show I think we all
love to talking to each other genuinely
it's very serious on this set we do not
play around oh I don't even want to know
I would rather come here than like
different acting techniques they
welcomed us into the family and it just
feels so loving just getting to work
with these amazing people and just
getting to learn from the best because
it doesn't feel like they're just
pretending they actually feel like
they're really close to us
she made me a note it's a near Tia you
are the best mother ever
and you care about me so much and I care
about you being together step in
together and pray
together RIT tees so you saw my dears
house now it's time to what
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]